[Music]
hello everybody I'm your host Diego
Lucca and welcome to us we have an
amazing show for you tonight
but first did you hear about this very
very interesting now apparently Disney
is coming up with a new musical yes it
involves a lot of white people on skates
apparently they're calling it hockey now
it's time for one of our favorite
segments singing on motorcycles in
traffic now today's guest is none other
than two-time Academy Award winner
Daniel day-lewis let's see how we do
[Applause]
oh good I would even say Shadow Ball
am i right haha seriously share it
please share it share it share it right
now click on the bottom click on it okay
hey it's time to introduce a very
special friend you know him it is Kevin
the IT guy I did not access to cannabis
that Oh
now Kevin tell us tell the folks at home
what did you do this weekend oh I made
my own dinner ooh interesting what what
did you have craisins mm-hmm asparagus
and I make my own seltzer okay I'm
together you are different from me and
that is funny to us ha ha ha now after
all the dinner I think the Kevin could
lose a few calories so it's time for now
with the help of our lovely and talented
Sophia what today we are going to teach
Kevin how to dance come on out give it
[Applause]
it's this outfit necessary all right
putting you down makes me look better
ah take it away Sophia we're going to
little bit chatter today here we go
it looks like Kevin was really feeling
it let's take a look at the replay
[Music]
but how great was Sophia am i right give
her a round of applause
now as many of you know next week I will
be on vacation have a good trip
oh thank you don't tell my wife she
knows she knows but I'm very excited to
announce who's gonna be filling in for
me next week now one of the most
talented comedians I know so funny she's
one of the most fun no or you can be any
guy that was a lot of fun almost as fun
as our bandleader
the DJ man I already told you I'm not in
the band
I'm Steve the script supervisor you
think I'm the DJ but I'm the only black
guy here yes hahaha
well we're not done with the phone just
yet now throughout the night we've been
telling Kevin that he's going to a
cooking show when in reality we're
sending him to meet notorious drug lord
and to go
[Applause]
love you now tune in next week when a
famous actress pretends to find me
charming in order to plug her movie and
until then
Buena Buena Buena oh I'll go sir all
right get me out of this place
thank you
[Music]